I think she must have known that but
something was wrong because obviously
she took herself to hospital and by the
time she realized something was wrong it
was already too late this is a really
nasty drug once it's in your system
there is nothing but we'll get it out
again and if you've taken as much as she
had if you've taken a lethal dose like
she did there is nothing they can do
other than try to sort of support your
system she she went to A&E she thought
they'd be able to help and they couldn't
you know it was it was desperate it must
been awful for the staff to be trying to
save her and to know that you know the
outcome was inevitable and I am so
grateful that you know they made the
effort to try and save her Sophia yeah
my message would be please don't please
don't take this drug and funeral why was
the I common evitable and how did they
break that news to you how were they
able they were able to do a toxicology
test on her which basically said she'd
taken too many pills
these were affecting her and they
couldn't dilute them there was nothing
they could do nothing they could do once
they were in her system and that you
know that's the danger if somebody makes
the mistake that my daughter did and
takes too many of these pills they the
doctors the staff if you go to hospital
you go to A&E they're not going to be
able to get them out of your system
you know they will take their toll and
it's an awful way to die you know they
cause you to overheat they cause your
kidneys to fail they you know they are
dreadful things and it's not not
something you want to do to yourself
I wouldn't wish this on anybody I know
it is just so raw with you and I'm so
brave of you speaking out because
obviously you don't want anyone else to
get into this situation and she was
taking these pills the irony is you look
at her you didn't realize you would
think you don't need to lose weight my
beautiful daughter she obviously thought
she did and
she's no different than so many people
who get themselves in this situation but
the warning is there with her death
Fiona really appreciate you talking
today and our condolences our heartfelt
condolences to you thank you very much
indeed thank you thank you for that
thank you